Land und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus und und herzlich
willkommen wollte ich sagen zu einer
Podcast Folge die fast nicht
stattgefunden hätte ich hörte heute
morgen von einem Kabelbruch bei dir ist
ein schönes Wort ein Kabelbruch ja ich
ich hab ich habe ja die Weihnachtszeit K
und den Anfang des januar zum Aufräumen
genutzt da habe ich mal das ganze
Podcast Equipment so richtig
professionell so eingerollt und
zusammengerollt und verpackt und so
weiter und die Folge war als ich
auseinander rollte war ein Stecker
kaputt ja den hatte ich irgendwie
verbogen dabei und das funktionierte
also beim allerbesten Willen nicht also
habe ich mich auf mein Fahrrad
geschwungen und bin zum ungefähr K weit
entfernten Saturn gedüst bei der Kälte
jetzt jetzt in Eiseskälte genau
unstellbar was du alles machst für
unsere Kleine agab ja genau und als ich
dann ankomme am Saturn stelle ich fest
dass ich mein Haustürschlüssel nicht
mitgenommen habe und damit auch mein
Fahrradschlüssel nicht so und jetzt
stand ich vor dem Problem die Zeit
drängt wir wollen aufnehmen ja ich muss
jetzt irgendetwas tun es gibt nur zwei
Möglichkeiten wieder zurückzufahren und
wertvolle Zeit zu verlieren oder mein
Fahrrad unabgeschlossen auf der Kühe
stehen zu lassen so so und wir hatten
uns ja überlegür du dich entschieden
hast ich weiß wür überlegt ja heute
daüber die Frage unter anderem zu zu
reden ob Deutschland verrot und ich habe
mir vorgenommen ich werde das Urteil
davon abhängig machen ob mein Fahrrad
dann ein paar Minuten später da noch
steht oder nicht ja okay so und das
Ergebnis ist Deutschland verrot nicht
man kann in Ruhe 10 Minuten lang sein
Fahrrad unabgeschlossen auf die köh
stellen wenn man Glück hat ja du ich ich
ich lass mein Fahrrad immer
unabgeschlossen stehen so h V bcker und
so weiter gehört und jeder weiß welche
fürchterlichen Konsequenzen droh nein
nein ich ich habe so ein Grundvertrauen
ich denkte ich ich habe auch schon
Fahrräder stehen lassen in der Hoffnung
dass sie endlich mal einer cllaut das
gebe ich auch zu ich bin ja so ein
Fahrradfahrer und aber ich lasse es ich
früher habe ich immer hysterisch alles
abgeschlossen mittlerweile mache ich das
nicht mehr
undälmrisch zum Land also dein Vertrauen
wächst in den gleichen Maße ind dem das
allgemeine Misstrauen zunimmt ja also
ich ich ich ich möchte gerne glauben
dass die Welt ein besserer Ort ist als
wir es manchmal so uns gegenseitig
erzählen und tatsächlich stell sich raus
das ist so ja weißt du was mich wirklich
beschäftigt hat zum zum Jahresanfang ist
dass es den Kaiser nicht mehr gibt das
Franz Beckenbauer gestauben ist das
stimmt das habe ich auch als Tiefe Tiefe
zesur empfunden ja und es ist für mich
so ein bisschen gleichbedeutend mit dem
Ende der alten
Bundesrepublik ja der Kaiser der Kaiser
die er war irgendwie vielleicht war er
nicht mehr irgendwann der Kaiser des
vereinten Deutschlands aber er war der
Kaiser der Bundesrepublik mhm also die
letzten Jahre wissen wir ja alle waren
für ihn jetzt nicht so glücklich die
waren hart ja die waren hart und ich
meine wir hätten auch schon mal darüber
geredet ja das lässt sich für mich in
wenigen Sätzen zusammenfassen er ist
einfach falsch beraten worden hätte
hätte er nicht auch sein Juristen gehört
sondern hätte sich auf seine entwaffn
Art hingestellt und hätte gesagt ja mai
ja für was 6,8 Weltmeisterschaft das die
billigste die je irgendwo verschärbelt
und verkauft wurde ja wir haben ein voll
das Schnäppchen gemacht und was habt ihr
denn geglaubt wegen schöner blauer Augen
kriegen wir eine Weltmeisterschaft ach
scheiße jetzt kommt mir mein scheiß h
dazwischen das lassen wir alles so drin
so ja was glaubt ihr wegen der schönen
blauen Augen kriegt er die
Weltmeisterschaft also wenn er sich
hingestellt hätte und sagt ihr man kennt
doch die FIFA ja man weiß wie der Hase
läuft und wir haben das auch noch
wahnsinnig günstig gemacht und haben
auch noch relativ wenige
m dann hätte sich strafbar gemacht aber
er wäre der Kaiser geblieben mhm ja das
ist wahr das das kriegt
hinten raus so so ein komischen dr ich
muss auch an dich denken du hast das ja
schon mal gesagt die die günstigste WM
aller Zeiten und eigentlich muss man ihm
für immer dankbar sein ja so eingetütet
hat ich ich habe ihn mal als als und
deswegen ist er mir so in Erinnerung
eine ganz kleine Anekdote aber eine die
von der ich glaube dass sie typisch ist
für ihn ich habe ihn als ganz junger
Radio da war ich noch Praktikant habe
ich ihn mal hier in Hamburg getroffen
und durfte ihm dann so Mikrofon unter
die Nase halten und und und durfte ihm
eine Frage stellen und die Art und Weise
wie er mich damals behandelt hat ich war
wirklich die unbedeutendste Leuchte
überhaupt in in in dieser in dieser
ganzen dieser ganzen Veranstaltung gab
das so eine große Pressekonferenz weiß
gar nicht mehr warum es ging aber die
Art und Weise wie er mich behandelt hat
das hat mich damals wahnsinnig
beeindruckt weil ich war ein ganz junger
Mensch von Anfang 20 Jahren und hatte
unglaublichen Respekt und irgendwie auch
Schiss und so weiter und war so me mein
erster kleiner Außeneinsatz und Franz
Beckenbauer jetzt zwei dre Fragen
stellen ja und diese nette entwaffnende
Art was man so dieses gute Freunde kann
niemand trennen weißt du so dieses ja so
wie er auch gesungen hat so war der auch
im so so so so ganz NRI der juvialität
ne ja genau ganz entspannt und komm wir
mal her und dann schauen wir mal und so
und dann sehen wir schon und so weißt du
denn noch was du ihn gefragt hast nee
ich ich weiß auch nicht mehr worum es
ging aber dieses Gefühl kann ich Dir
sehr genau beschreiben und es gab
interessanterweise noch einen zweiten
der in in dieser in diese rieege für
mich reingehört das ist Ulli Wickert mit
schönen Grüßen an dieser Stelle den habe
ich mal besucht da war der große Mister
tagesthem und so weiter und der war
genauso der der hat mich da in seinem
Büro da in beim NDR empfangen und
und die die Art und Weise wie er das so
gemacht hat das war
unheimlichpann am alte Bundesrepublik ne
Ulli wickard ja
ja sagen ja ohne das jetzt böse zu
machen nein nein nein das meine ich auch
bei bei Beckenbauer nicht böse sondern
das sind einfach einfach Figuren die man
mit einer früheren Zeit verbindet so als
regelmäßige Instanzen mhm wo man sich
dann eine Zeit lang die Welt gar nicht
vielleicht ohne vorstellen kann mhm und
wo man denkt würden die heute noch in
die Zeit passen ja was was wären solche
Leute heute wären die noch in diesen
Positionen hätten die noch diese
Bedeutung und da hat man das Gefühl ist
seitdem irgendwie ganz viel Zeit
vergangen ja es ist viel Zeit vergangen
und bringt uns eigentlich auch direkt
zum Thema Richard ich standen diese
Leute und stehen Sie im Falle von Uli
Wickert nicht war auch immer noch für
eine wie soll man das sagen für so eine
gewisse Versöhnlichkeit
äh ich ich ich ich habe das Gefühl dass
diese Kompromisslosigkeit die sich
gerade auf ganz vielen Ebenen Z Bahn
bricht jeder regt sich auf jeder ist
sauer jeder und und viele sind auch
berechtigt sauer we weil finde im Moment
auch gerade diese Regierung politisch
echt kein gutes Handwerk abliefert das
sagen die sogar selber in dieser Woche
ein Gespräch mit Anton Hofreiter der der
sagte boah das ist ist einfach nicht gut
wenn du mal hörst wie diese diese diese
agrariesel Geschichte z.B zustande
gekommen ist ger vorher noch einhaken
Markus wenn du sagst das wird hört man
ja in letzter Zeit ganz oft und wird ja
auch wahrscheinlich richtig sein dass
ihr kein gutes Handwerk liefert woran
glaubst du liegt das wo lernt man das
Handwerk der Politik mm und warum wird
dieser Begriff Handwerk eigentlich jetzt
immer nur im negativen benutzt ne also
man sagt nie die haben gutes Handwerk
gemacht in der Politik sondern ist nur
die Rede von schlechtem
Handwerk ja na ich würde das nicht so
sagen ich finde die haben ja gutes
Handwerk abgeliefert z.B als es um um um
diese gasmangellage ging die da drohte
letzter Winter versetz dich mal 12
Monate zurück da haben die richtig gutes
Handwerk abgeliefert ich meine die die
die Drohung war oder die die das
Szenario das so über allem schwebte war
wir sitzen frierend in unseren Wohnungen
und sie haben es l abgeräumt es
geschafft aber weißt du was ich glaube
was einer der wichtigen Gründe ist und
das wäre auch eine schöne Einleitung in
die Bauern Proteste sag wenn man sich
überlegt wie kommen wohl solche
Entscheidungen zustande also es heißt ja
immer die werden ganz kleinen Kreis
getroffen werden ja also Lindner habbeck
und Scholz sitzen zusammen beim Kaffee
oder od beim Bier und denken jetzt
müssen wir mal ein paar Milliarden
einsparen wo gehen wir mal
ran dann überlegt man sich doch wir
gehen am besten daran wo es am wenigsten
auffhällt und der Protest am geringsten
ist das wäre die nahliegenste Reaktion
und sonst hätte man ja sagen können also
gehen wir doch mal an die Baustellen
dran an die wir schon immer rangehen
wollten Kerosin besteuern ja es ist
völlig unnachvollziehbar warum
Flugbenzin in Deutschland nicht
besteuert wird ich überg oh dann bringen
wir aber die Fluggesellschaften gegen un
dann verteuern sich die Urlaube ja und
die Leute sind gerade wieder so
reisefreudig muss du wiedersprechen das
ist Gen das das perfekte Beispiel für
schlechtes Handwerk weil weil und und
das ist das was glaube ich so viele
Leute nicht verstehen dass das Profis ja
Christian Lindner Profis passiert wenn
du wenn du sagst wir schaffen jetzt die
Subventionierung für Kerosin ab was
macht dann eine Fluggesellschaft
die Preise erhöhen sie fliegt einfach
zum Tanken woanders hin ganz einfach so
wie wir es früher in Südtirol auch mal
gemacht hab wir sind zum Tanken nach
Österreich gefahren das meine mein Vater
ist zum Tanken nach Österreich so und
die Fliegen halt zum Tanken nach egal
wohin du mein da kann man keine
Regelungen schaffen die das unterbinden
und du meinst das werden alle
Fluggesellschaften für alles machen auch
für Inlandsflüge die die können es auf
ke Fall die können es im großen Stil
machen doch und das ich weiß ich weiß
das ich weiß das von von Leuten die mir
das auch so sagt haben einfach nicht
drüber nachgedacht nicht überlegt zu
schnell zu schnell diese Entscheidung
getroffen gesagt machen wir jetzt
einfach Kerosin Rums weg mit der
Subvention um dann festzustellen ach du
meine Güte dann fliegen die halt zum
Tanken ins Ausland ja aber selbst wenn
die Hälfte zum Tanken ins Ausland fliegt
käme immer noch gigantische Summen dabei
raus also deutlich
mehr beim Diesel der Bauern ja das ist
das eine so was die Bauern z.B angeht
gut die können nicht ins Ausland gehen
und da tanken das verstehe ich schon
also warum ist am Ende bei den Bauern
hängen geblieben man könnte ja auch den
Bundestag verkleinern würde auch einige
hert Millionen mit eingespart werden
können man könnte endlich das
Steuerprivileg auf Dienstwagen angehen Z
da gehe ich nicht ins
Ausland also wenn das kirosin nicht
gehen sollte was ich noch lange nicht
für bewiesen halte es gibt ja so viele
Sachen die man machen kann irgendeiner
von den dreien muss gesagt haben dann
fangen wir eben beim Trecker Diesel an
ja da würde ich gerne wissen wer und
warum der der und aber das ist doch der
Eindruck der da entsteht es entsteht
dann die absurde Situation da sitzen
diese drei Leute zusammen und
beschließen das dann stellt sich
öffentlich der Landwirtschaftsminister
der zuständige Minister hin und und
konkariert seine eigene Regierung nicht
irgendeine seine eigene Regierung er
Teil dies Regung nicht kriegen ja sagt
ich ich habe die davor gewarnt wie kann
man bloß sowas machen völlig verrückt
dann sagt Christian Lindner ja also das
müssen wir natürlich nicht so machen das
können wir irgendwie auch anders machen
und der Kanzler hat Corona also
verstehst du de das wir doch alles total
le lepsch nach Kassenlage was machen wir
denn mal mit der Idee ja bist du dagegen
ja ist okay können wir machen ja ist ja
klar der zuständige Bundesminister ist
immer dagegen wenn wir jetzt
verteidigungsagekürz wä der
Verteidigungsminister dagegen gewesen
bildungsetageekürz wir Bildungsminister
dagegen
gewesen normalerweise hätte dann der
zuständige Minister erstmal nichts
gesagt und nicht sofort den Keil
reingetrieben damit er die Prügel nicht
abkriegt dann die Ministerpräsidenten
die sich hinter die Bauern stellen und
sagen ja wir sind es nicht gewesen die
sind zwar von unser Partei aber wir
waren es nicht genau Stefan weil der
viele Bauern in Niedersachsen hat
Manuela Schwesig die ganz ganz viele
Bauern in Mecklenburg Vorpommern hat die
sich gegen den eigenen Kanzler stellen
und du hast recht Null Zusammenhalt in
der Partei jeder kämpft für sich für
sein Ansehen und dass er gesund aus der
Sache rauskommt genau und ich habe bei
beim beim Landwirtschaftsminister und
ohne da jemandem zu nah treten zu wollen
aber ich sag mal so es kostet dich
nichts dich auf eine Bühne zu stellen
und zu sagen ja ich war ja dagegen
übrigens also das ich bin völlig eurer
Meinung wenn du so wirklich komplett und
aus tiefster Überzeugung dagegen bist
dann ist die Konsequenz wenn ihr es
trotzdem macht trete ich zurück das
macht die mit mir nicht und da muss man
mal erinnern an Leute wie wie Frau
leuthäuser Schnarrenberger z.B großer
Lauschangriff mhm die Justizministerin
war und gesagt hat pass auf wenn ihr das
macht nicht mit mir geht gegen meine
tiefe Überzeugung das mache ich nicht
mit ich trete zurück aber aber zu sagen
ich ich war ja dagegen und ich habe es
den ja noch gesagt und so weiter das ist
das kostet dich nichts aber es hat keine
Konsequenz ziemlich lauwarm ne ja ja
finde
ich wie das entstanden ist und wie das
dann passiert ist und so weiter also das
hat mit Handwerk alles überhaupt gar
nichts zu tun das freine Schusterei und
ich weiß gar nicht also das macht den
Eindruck natürlich überhaupt nicht dass
das irgendwie fähige Leute sind die sich
das ganz genau und gut überlegt haben
dann hätte man auch den Öz mir da vorher
zur Rate ziehen müssen und dann hätte
man entweder hätte zurücktreten müssen
oder hätte sich dahinterstellen M also
du hast ja zwei Möglichkeiten entweder
klar NEIN zu sagen JA oder zu sagen okay
finde ich zwar nicht gut aber wenn wir
das entschieden haben muss ich das
Tragen ja aber nicht sich dazwischen hin
und her zu Punkt erstmal ein Punkt dann
vertreten wir es gemeinsam nach außen
geht noch weiter ich mit dem
brandenburgischen
bauernverbandspräsidenten in dieser
Woche gesprochen mit Herrn Wendorf der
auch interessanter Mann Ökobauer hat 950
Hektar ist jemand der mit 220 000 €
Subventionen kriegt jedes Jahr und der
der der trotzdem sehr nachvollziehbar
mal erklärt hat wie das Ganze so läuft
ja und das sozusagen die die die das die
die die mehr vom reichen Bauern der ja
gar kein Risiko mehr hat und einfach
subvensioniert wird und so weiter und
den geht's doch eh allen gut der hat
damit mal aufgeräumt das fand ich sehr
interessant wie er das erklärt hat und
erzählt hat wovon die eigentlich
abhängig sind gab's ein paar sehr sehr
gute Argumente in dem Gespräch aber der
sagt mit uns hat keiner geredet mm wie
kann das sein die kriegen dann aus dem
aus dem Fernsehen oder perortte de Mufti
einfach angesagt ja ist dann ebeno und
natürlich kann man das so machen ich
verstehe das schon je mehr du Vorschläge
nach außen gibst desto mehr wird's ja
auch immer zerredet das verstehe ich
alles man kann das so machen aber ist es
klug es so zu machen ich finde nichtm
nee also ein klugen Eindruck macht er
gar nichts aber lass uns mal auf die
Situation der Landwirte du hast ja
gesagt er hat ja gerade erklärt äh wie
sich die reale Situation der Landwirte
darstellt traust du dir das zu da so ein
kleines Tableau mal zu malen und zu
sagen wie geht's dem durchschnittlichen
deutschen Landwirt ja weißt du was das
Interessante ist ist wir haben ja in
diesen Tagen ganz viel gehört von dem
durchschnittlichen deutschen Bauern ne
darüber haben wir ganz viel gesprochen
ja das Interessante ist aber wenn du da
mal genauer hinschaust den
durchschnittlichen deutschen Bauern gibt
es überhaupt nicht ne es gibt sozusagen
die die die Großgrundbesitzer es gibt
dann Agrarfabriken genau agrarfabrik es
gibt es gibt die großen Konzerne es gibt
die großen Handelskonzerne es gibt z
landwischaftliche Intensivhaltung mit
tausenden von Tieren ja so wenn man sich
mal z.B jetzt die Situation von von
Henrik Wendorf anguckt der hat diese 950
Hektar damit ist er sagt er in
Brandenburg ein mittelgroßer Betrieb in
Mecklenburg
Vorpommern gibt's noch größere Betriebe
wenn du wiederum nach Bayern guckst dann
wäre der ein gigantisch großer Betrieb
der Grund ist übrigens klar ne in im
Osten war ein LPGs ja exakt da war ja
die Tradition des kleinbauerntums von
der DDR aufgehoben worden genau ja bis
auf die wenigen die da wieder auf ihre
Höfe zurückgegangen zurückgekommen sind
ist natürlich der der größte Teil dann
an ein großerzeuger gegangen und das ist
natürlich in in Regionen die eine
ungebrochene Familienbauernhof Tradition
haben wie in Bayern oder in
BadenWürttemberg natürlich anders genau
so das heißt auch da siehst du schon den
Bauern gibt's gar nicht er hat ungefähr
die Hälfte dieser 950 Hektar gehören ihm
die andere Hälfte hat er ungefähr
angemietet angepachtet sozusagen sagen
und da siehst du schon wie schwierig es
wird wenn man plötzlich anfängt so über
den Bauern zu reden ja äh der
Durchschnitt die Statistik sagt dir eine
Bauernfamilie in der drei
Familienmitglieder arbeiten die kam im
Wirtschaftsjahr 22 23 letztes Jahr auf
fast 250 000 € Bruttoeinkommen man
könnte also sagen auf jeden
selbständigen Bauern fallen rechnerisch
ungefähr knapp 82 000 € Vorsteuer
gewinnen das ist das Einkommen eines mit
inas oder ist WE oberstleutenanz oder so
äh und die diese weit mehr als der deuts
das deutsche Durchschnittseinkommen
genau so so klingt das erstmal sagt mal
was für ein Thema habt ihr denn
eigentlich und jetzt reden wir darüber
auch da wieder ein 100 Hektar Betrieb
z.B kriegt ungefähr
2000 paar zerquetschte Euro
agrardieselerstattung pro Jahr so und
dann sagt warte mal also im Schnitt habt
ihr jetzt hier diese 250.000 €
Bruttoeinkommen und und dann fallen
jetzt diese 2100 € Weg wo ist denn
eigentlich euer Problem gleichzeitig
auch da wieder Schnitt ungefähr
40% des Einkommens von und oder des
Gewinns den Bauern machen 40% stammt aus
Subvention also könnte man sagen ist
eine wahnsinnig gepemperte Branche na ja
also und und wenn man sagt wenn man sagt
Höfe sterben und so weiter ja wir müssen
das verhindern also ich erinnere mal in
dem Zusammenhang daran wie Bäckereien
gestorben sind und gerade Bäckereien
sterben und niemand kam auf die Idee
Bäckereien zu sub oder früher Tante Emma
leden so z. so in meiner Jugend ja genau
aber es gibt einen großen Unterschied
und der Unterschied ist es gibt einen
politischen Willen dass es eine breit
diversifizierte deutsche Landwirtschaft
gibt und das Lebensmittel billig sind
möglichst vielen Bauern genau also nicht
nur ganz wenigen großerzeugern sondern
mit möglichst vielen Bauern das ist ja
politisch
gewünscht und dafür wird es
subventioniert und zwar gigantisch
subventioniert in erster Linie aus
Brüssel ne jeder dritte Euro aus dem
euaushalt geht irgendwo in Europa in die
Landwirtschaftspolitik es ist mit der
größte Etat der Europäischen Union
überhaupt richtig und das Geld was die
EU zur Verfügung hat und das Geld was
die Bundesrepublik zur Verfügung hat um
ihre Bauern subventionieren ist
Steuergeld das heißt es ist ein Trick
damit die Agrarprodukte ja die Butter
und die und so weiter nicht das kosten
was sie eigentlich in der Erzeugung
kosten wird das Ganze subventioniert und
den Leuten wird das Geld über Steuern
abgenommen damit i nicht auffällt was
Lebensmittel tatsächlich kosten richtig
richtig ja das heißt es ist politisch
gewollt dass wir gute und möglichst
günstige Lebensmittel haben und insofern
kommt ein ganz großer Teil dieser
Subvention dann natürlich wieder am Ende
bei uns bei den Verbrauchern bei den
Steuerzahlern an das ist alles politisch
so gewollt genau aber jetzt habe ich in
dieser Woche mit mit Christian Lohmeier
geredet ein sehr sehr interessanter Mann
Bauer aus Niedersachsen dessen Hof
gerade auch so so halb unter Wasser
steht und mit dem ich schon mal im
Oktober vergangenen Jahres ein sehr
interessantes Gespräch hatte über über
den Wolf
ähm und der mittlerweile seine seine
scharfherde verkaufen musste weil er
diese diese wolfrisse hat und so weiter
und weil äh er einfach keine Zukunft für
sich als als Schafzüchter mehr dort
sieht wegen der paar Wölfe bevor wieder
in
wolfpraganda weil ich bin ja auf der
Gegenseite ich bin ja ich bin ja Team
Wolf ne also ich halte das nach wie vor
übertrieben das ist Christian Loher auch
und ich übrigens auch
das H schon h böse Argumente ja der arme
arme Schafbauer wenn er sein zerrissenes
Schaf da liegen sieht und so weiter da
hast du schon ganz viel dich gegen den
Wolf ausgesprochen hat nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein ist völlig
falsch Richard wirklich ist wichtig ich
bin total teamwolf Christian Lohmeier
der Schafbauer der so viele Schafe
verloren hat durch den Wolf ist auch
total teamwolf der sagt das ist im
Verhalten dieser Tiere drin das kann ich
dem überhaupt nicht übel nehmen das ist
nicht das Thema den Regen ganz andere
Dinge auf die Ökologen die dahinter
sitzen und den Wolf wieder ansiedeln er
magt Wölfe aber er magt die Leute nicht
die die Wölfe ne nee auch nicht nee das
ist eben nein deswegen mag ich den weil
Christian Loher ist eben kein das ist
das ist nicht irgendwie so eine
reaktionäre Dumpfbacke sondern das ist
ein sehr smarter intelligenter Mann wie
viele Bauern übrigens sind sehr gut
ausgebildete Leute die unheimlich viel
drauf haben müssen auch um das zu machen
was sie da machen die deutsche
Meisterprüfung in der Landwirtschaft
gilt als eine der schwierigsten wenn
nicht die schwierigste in der Welt so
also nirgendwo in der Welt werden Bauern
so gut ausgebildet wie in Deutschland ja
und Herr Wendorf z.B der der Ökobauer
aus Brandenburg der hat elf Bodenpunkte
weißt du was Bodenpunkte sind ja
erklärst mal pass auf kannte ich auch
vorher nicht den Begriff es gibt
sozusagen ein einen ein eine
Bemessungsgrundlage für die Qualität von
Böden und wenn du in Brandenburg Bauer
bist und und da merkst du plötzlich dass
es eben auch da ne es gibt den Bauern
nicht und die große fette Subvention und
das ist alles kein Problem wenn du wenn
du in Brandenburg bist auf diesen
sandigen Böden meinte er wortwörtlich in
der Sendung musst du echt was drauf
haben wenn du aus diesen sandigen Böden
was rausholen willst das ist ganz anders
als beispielsweise rund um Magdeburg wo
ja die besten Magdeburger Börde genau wo
so die besten Böden in Deutschland sind
genau Ukraine ist z.B so ein Fall die
haben das geht von ich glaube von 0 bis
100 Ukraine ist fast 100 die haben
unfassbar gute fruchtbare Böden aber in
Brandenburg sieht die Welt eben anders
ziemlich viel Sand genau und äh wenn
wenn du dann eben mit diesen Leuten
sprichst wir waren jetzt beim Wolf
gerade das Thema ist nicht der Wolf das
Thema ist sozusagen das was die Politik
in dem Fall den Leuten vorgibt die sagen
pass auf ihr lebt jetzt bitte damit wir
haben jetzt diese Vorgabe wir machen das
jetzt so und jetzt lebt bitte damit dann
gibt es irgendwann die Erkenntnis oh so
geht das irgendwie nicht weiter weil wir
gefährden hier auch die
Existenzgrundlage von Leuten und das
könnte irgendwann auch für Menschen
möglicherweise gefährlich werden dann
sagt man okay wir entnehmen das jetzt
ist das schöne Wort für abschießen entn
Namen der Fachbegriff genau ich habe
Herrn Lohmeier gefragt wie viele Wölfe
sind denn jetzt entnommen worden in
Niedersachsen er sagt kein einziger kein
einziger warum weil jeder Jäger der
damit möglicherweise beauftragt wird
sagt die Verantwortung ist mir viel zu
groß weil wenn der Wolf auch nur 1 m
außerhalb deines Grundstücks ist und
irgendjemand weiß mir das nach dann
stehe ich mit einem halben Bein schon
wieder im Knast das heißt du musst dich
absichern der Wolf kommt aber dann am 25
dezember ist gerade Weihnachten alle
sitzen unterm Tannenbaum das ist dem
Wolf aber wurscht wen rufst du dann an
welche Behörde hat dann Zeit für dich um
zu entscheiden okay jetzt können wir
diesen Wolf der jetzt gerade hier ein
Problem macht den können wir jetzt
entnehmen weißt du das ist das Thema der
Leute es ist diese Sprunghaftigkeit W
hat noch viele andere Beispiele genannt
z.B wollen wir Markus wollen wir mal von
den ganz großen und wichtigsten Thema
Deutschlands dem Wolf wieder
zurückkommen zu dem weit weniger
wichtigen Thema der
wutbauern keine wutbau wir machen
irgendwann noch mal eine wolfssendung
und dann gehen wir das wirklich jeden
einzelnen Schritt durch rich ich will
dir nur sagen es gibt es also wenn du
wenn du versuchst mal zu ergründen und
das war so spannend in dieser Woche was
eigentlich wirklich dahinter ist ich
habe das ja auch nie geglaubtmer sagt
nein das GLB glaube ich nicht dass jetzt
diese Subvention die keine riesige
Subvention ist die bringt jetzt Leute so
dermaßen auf die Straße und so auf die
Palme was ist denn da eigentlich noch
DIN muss der letzte Tropfen gewesen sein
ne das F ich würde auch gerne mal einen
Aspekt rein psychologischen Aspekt also
Bauer ist ja eigentlich das älteste
Gewerbe der Welt ne also vorher kann man
ja nicht von Beruf sprechen also Jäger
und Sammler war irgendwie kein richtiger
Beruf aber als man dann so anfing in der
Jungsteinzeit sesshaft zu werden
entstand überhaupt irgendwie sowas was
man sich unter einem Beruf
vorstellte das ist in die ins Leben ne
genau das ist also Bauer ja vielleicht
ist Schamane noch ein älterer Beruf als
Bauer aber aber Bauer ist ein sehr alter
Beruf und das gehört natürlich zu
Freiheit Unternehmertum ja existenzielle
Auseinandersetzung mit Natur und Umwelt
und so weiter es ist so ein auf den
ersten Blick ist es ja so ein so so sehr
freier Beruf auch ne draußen in der
Natur zu sein im frei zu sein und dann
eben selber zu überlegen baue ich das an
mache ich das schaffe ich mir noch mehr
Kühe an reduziere ich meine Bestände und
so weiter auf der einen Seite und das
ist auch für das Selbstbewusstsein
scheint mir immer so zu sein der
Bäuerinnen und Bauern unheimlich wichtig
und auf der anderen Seite ist das ein
bürokratisch bis zum geht nicht mehr
eingehegter Bereich genau man ist
abhängig von Subventionen eben auch ganz
vielen aus Brüssel man wird von von
Brüssel aus im Grunde genommen wie der
Stier am Nasenring ja durch den Stall
geführt und wenn man dann überlegt und
die Höhe der Subventionen sich anguckt
dann gibt es nur noch Beamte die stärker
vom Staat subventioniert werden als
Bauern das heißt also alles Dinge die
dem dem eigentlichen ETOS des Bauern
widersprechen und auch ein gefilz von
Bürokratie und Gängelungen und
Vorschriften und so weiter und es kommt
natürlich durch die ökologische wänd
noch mehr und mehr und mehr dazu und
Tierwohl dazu und so weiter dass man
irgendwie so ein unheimlichen Groll
entwickelt gegen
Schreibtischtäter ja und das Gefühl hat
all die Leute die gar keine richtigen
Berufe haben ja sondern nur so so
abgeleitete sekundär oder tertiärberufe
mit Schlips und Kragen als
Sachverständiger irgendwo zu sitzen und
die Leute entscheiden jetzt über mein
Hof oder meine Existenz das ist so ein
grunddilemma das ist im Grunde genommen
schon alt ja das ist Jahrzehnte alt aber
das ist doch irgendwas wo ich immer das
Gefühl habe wenn ich mit Landwirten Rede
was nagt ja und und was total ört und
was ärgert und irgendwie ist so dieses
Gefühl da ich will meine Freiheit zurück
ja da triffst du genau den Punkt um den
es geht glaube ich auch das merkst Du
auch wenn man mit jemandem wie Christian
Lohmeier spricht die haben halt erlebt
in in den letzten Jahren dass einfach
unfassbar viele Änderungen gekommen sind
und er sagte selber in der Sendung weißt
du ich würde ab morgen sofort auf all
diese Subvention verzichten weil ich hab
dieser Tage interessanten Begriff
gelesen von auch von einem Bauern der
sagte weißt du die Wahrheit ist doch wir
sind doch eigentlich EU
teilzeitbeamte ja weil 40% unseres
Gewinns kriegen wir quasi aus der EU was
aber heißt und das empfindet eben auch
jemand wie Loher der sagt wir sind
kompletter pressbar wir sind total
abhängig von den z.B Wolf jetzt noch mal
Wolf dann sagen die du magst es nicht
hören dann sagt er
z.B gibt's dann die die Idee die
Vorschrift Hirtenhund ja der wird dann
auch subventioniert und so weiter sagt
wenn morgen irgendeiner von denen
entscheidet und sagt nee jetzt nicht
mehr Hirtenhund jetzt machen wir es noch
mal ganz anders dann habe ich ein
Problem wie mache ich es dann
stattdessen das gleiche bei stellen die
die Frage wie musst du in Zukunft einen
Stall ausgestalten völlig unklar hat
dazu geführt dass die Investitionen in
der Landwirtschaft enorm zurückgegangen
sind dann hast du diese diese
Veränderungen diese die Digitalisierung
der Landwirtschaft die haben ein
demografisches Problem viele finden
keinen Nachfolger mehr ja ja das heißt
mit der digitalisier schönes Problem
dazu die EU ja begrüßt es je größer der
Hof ist umso mehr Kohle gibt es so und
jetzt ist die EU subventioniert auch
hochgradig wenn du baust also nicht Land
da sondern stelle drauf stellst und so
weiter das wird alles von der EU
gefördert gefördert und gefördert das
machst du ja du wächst um zu überleben
weil du doch immer wieder neue
Fördermittel kriegst muss sich natürlich
weiterhin Verschulden ja die
Verschuldung in der Landwirtschaft ist
gigantisch an die Bank
und es gibt sozusagen einen von der EU
vorgegebenen wachstumsmechanismus aus
dem man kaum rauskommt ich verstehe bis
heute nicht ja warum daran so ein großes
Interesse besteht wenn wir auf der
anderen Seite Familienunternehmen
Kleinbauern und so weiter fördern wollen
und gerade diverse Landschaften erhalten
wollen wir keine Monokulturen wollen
wenn wir Bauern auch als
Landschaftspfleger sehen weil wir sagen
das sind hochwertige Kulturlandschaften
das passt doch alles überhaupt nicht z
also ich habe das Gefühl ähnlich wie das
bei der Rente ist oder im
Gesundheitssystem ja es ist ein total
verkorstes System ja und selbst wenn
wenn man selber morgen
Landwirtschaftsminister würde mal
abgesehen davon der deutsche
Landwirtschaftsminister ja eine arme Sau
was hat er denn überhaupt zu sagen was
haben wir nicht alles an Kompetenzen
nach Brüssel ausgelagert und da muss man
ganz ehrlich die Frage stellen ja es
wäre doch vielleicht gar nicht verkehrt
wenn wir einige dieser Kompetenzen
wieder zurückbekämen aber sozusagen eine
Rück lung innerhalb der Europäischen
Union ist ebenfalls im System nicht
vorgesehen dass man sagt ja okay da sind
wir ein bisschen zu weit gegangen das
machen wir das renationalisieren wir mal
wieder passiert ja so gut wie gar nicht
mm also da gibt's schon wirklich
ernsthafte Probleme und ich glaube da
gibt so ein gefilz ja von Motiven die
mal abgesehen von den ganz handfesten
Motiven das ein kleiner Betrieb jetzt
ernsthaft getroffen wird davon dass sein
Diesel nicht mehr subventioniert wird
aber das eigentliche Hauptproblem da
wirklich daran besteht dass die Bauern
irgendwie das Gefühl haben sie machen
nicht selber sondern es wird von ihnen
mit ihnen gemacht und es wird von Leuten
mit ihnen gemacht die keine Ahnung haben
genau das eine hast du gerade
angesprochen Richard viele Bauern haben
hohe Schulden haben hohe Kredite
aufgenommen um beispielsweise Stelle zu
bauen nach Auflagen die heute dann aber
schon nicht mehr gelten ja ja also was
was was was rüstest du dann um was
rüstest du nach
wann investierst du beispielsweise ja
wann wann kaufst du Maschinen wie ist in
dem Moment gerade der Weizenpreis und so
weiter ja und dann hast du z.B weil ich
gerade sagte Digitalisierung also es
gibt es gibt Dinge die die die war mir
so z.B überhaupt nicht klar es gibt seit
neuesten die Situation dass Anbauflächen
von Satelliten und von Drohnen überwacht
werden das heißt alle paar Tage prüfter
Satellit ob da wirklich dasau das macht
aber nicht der Bauer selber ne das
machen die diejenigen die über die
Subventionen Wachen und gucken dass du
ja bloß nichts Verbotenes Anbau aus so
da dann schaut man okay stimmt das ja
ist da das auf angebaut was in den
Anträgen in den Förderanträgen aneben
wurde ja wenn der Satellit sagt da
wächst jetzt kein Weizen sondern
meinetwgen Mais dann muss der Landwirt
mit Foto beweisen dass der Satellit sich
irrt und dafür muss er dann z.B eine App
installieren und wenn du jetzt gerade
Demografie ansprichst ja ältere Leute
ältere Bauern die tun sich wahnsinnig
schwer damit ja da muss muss diese App
vstellung
nicht ja man man gehört allein durch die
Tatsache dass es das gibt einer latent
kriminalisierten Bevölkerungsgruppe ab
GLB die müsen mal in aller Ruhe
bespitzeln weil den trauen wir nicht
mehr über den Weg ja weißt du was
interessant ist du drehst sozusagen ein
ganz wichtiges Prinzip unseres
Rechtsstaats drehst du einfach um du
drehst die Beweislast um der Bauer muss
dir nachweisen dass er dort das richtige
bitte anpflanzt ja der Mann der sein
Land so gut kennt wie kein anderer und
wenn du jetzt gerade über Land sprichst
die kriegen z.B auch Subventionen dafür
dass sie 4% ihrer Fläche ich mit mit
Christian Loher gesprochen 4% ihrer
Fläche quasi so einfach so so ruhen
lassen Stichworte Biodiversität Arten
viel was eine sehr richtige und gute
Idee ist sagst dir so in seinem verständ
ja in seinem ich verstehe den Gedanken
dahinter aber in seinem Verständnis ist
es so dass er sagt warte mal Markus kann
das ernsthaft sein dass wir einen einen
einen hochprofitablen Boden ein Boden
der richtig was könnte den legen wir
absichtlich
brach und alle paar Minuten verhungert
irgendwo auf der Welt ein Kind verträgt
sich mit meinen ethisch moralischen
Ansprüchen gar nicht das ist qu ver
totaler Quatsch warum ist qu glaubst du
denn dass wenn diese randbestände die da
übrig bleiben ja und die bewirtschaftet
werden wenn die jetzt auch noch genutzt
werden um Weizen anzubauen oder um mal
realistisch zu sein 60% der Anbau
flächen in Deutschland ja ist
tierfutterproduktion und diese Rinder
würden nicht ja oder diese Schweine
würden nicht irgendwo in der Dritten
Welt ein Kind ernähren das ist totaler
Schwachsinn das stimmt einfach nicht
also ich habe ja jetzt hier viele Lanzen
für den Bauern gebrochen ja aber das ist
wirklich übelste Propaganda dass wir
hier bestimmte Bereiche bestimmte
Bereiche ich erzähle ja mal eine
Geschichte die ich mir dazu immer
einfällt John Stewart Mill der große
Philosoph John Stuart Mill Mitte des 19
Jahrhunderts 1800 48 ein Buch
geschrieben über politische Ökonomie und
in dem sagt er der Kapitalismus ist doch
eine großartige Sache damals redet mir
überwiegend noch von Landwirtschaft ja
und das ist doch super wenn die Farmer
in England das Land nutzen die Wälder
Roden um daraus Landwirtschaft zu machen
und mit Hilfe dieser Landwirtschaft die
Bevölkerung zu ernähren das ist das
Beste was überhaupt tun können nur dann
kann die Bevölkerung auf wachsen es ist
genug Nahrungsmittel da und so weiter
nur fragt er dann zwischen den Zeilen in
einem kurzen Abschnitt
ja wenn wir dieses Prinzip was ja völlig
richtig ist ja dass wir allen Boden
brauchen um die Menschen zu ernähren
konsequent ernst neehmen dann wird es
eines Tages keinen einzigen Baum in
England mehr geben und wenn was für
England gilt gilt für alles andere auch
und so weiter und irg Osterinsel ist das
schöne Beispiel ja irgendwann kom
irgendwann kommen wir an einen Punkt ja
wo wir sagen müssen das Prinzip mag
richtig sein aber es gilt nicht
unbegrenzt ja weil wir gleichzeitig ganz
ganz viel damit zerstören z.B in unserem
Fall die insektenvielfalt und Vogelwelt
und alles was damit zusammeng gehört ein
Thema was ökologisch immer leicht
unterschätzt wird wiln man denkt es geht
ums zwitchern im Garten ne es geht da um
ganz ganz grundsätzliche und wichtige
Dinge dabei und deswegen bin ich absolut
dafür das bestimmte das sind ja relativ
kleine Prozentsätze die da übrig
geblieben lassen damit sich da ein
bisschen restnatur erholen kann die
Landwirtschaft ist unter ökologischen
Gesichtspunkten eine der größten
Probleme der Welt ja ja das ist das
würde ich niemals einem einzelnen Bauern
sagen du bist das jetzt Schuld oder du
machst den falschen Beruf weil ich habe
ja auch die ganze Zeit eine Lanze jetzt
für die Bauern gebrochen ja noch nicht
für den Wolf aber da für den Wolf schon
für für den für die wolffeinde das finde
ich an den Haaren herbeigezogen da
bleibe ich auch bei ja gut aber egal weg
vom Wolf weg vom Wolf also der
ökologische der ökologische
Gesichtspunkt ökologischen
Gesichtspunkte sind nicht verhandelbar
ja die die nehmen wir zurecht ernst und
die müssen wir in Zukunft mehr ernst
genauso wie ich den Bauern und sein
Schicksal ja in der Brüsseler
Planwirtschaft ernst nehme also wir
müssen beides ernst nehmen ist ja kein
entweder oderau ja ich ich dieses
psychologische Momentum darin das das
ist mir in dieser Woche auch klar
geworden ist total wichtig und ehrlich
gesagt auch die Doppelmoral und die die
die Scheinheiligkeit die da drin ist ich
hab in in in dieser Woche interessanten
interessantes Interview gehört mit Karin
Duwe Schriftstellerin äh die in
Brandenburg lebt interessante Frau die
eine ganz andere Position betritt die
sagt es ist unsolidarisch ja in einer
Zeit in der wir so mit Katastrophen zu
tun haben alle müssen sparen und das
müssen auch die Bauern ja und da gab's
diese Gewinnsteigerung von von 23% und
so weiter und ich habe mehrfach in
dieser Woche auch aus dem Jahresbericht
des Bauernverbandes zitiert wo die
festgehalten haben dass ist ein ein paar
zwei sehr sehr gute Jahre waren und dass
die Zufriedenheit unter den Bauern so
hoch ist wie seit 2014 nicht mehr das
ist ganz aktueller
Jahresbericht das passt halt so gar
nicht zu dem was ich da gerade bahnbrcht
so und Karin du argumentiert so die sagt
die die selbst Verursacher des
Klimawandels sind niemals dafür gerade
stehen für das was sie da selbst
verursachen geht so in deine Richtung
gerade ne die es kann nicht sein dass
immer die Allgemeinheit für die
mitbezahlen muss ich würde sagt sie alle
Subventionen reichen hat in Neuseeland
auch geklappt
sie weigern sich das Grundwasser nicht
mehr zu vergiften wir haben ein ein
Verhalten dass wir den sozusagen Geld
dafür bezahlen dass sie nicht mehr Gülle
ins Trinkwasser kippen das ist
schutzgeldverhalten also quasi
Erpressung und das ist aber genau das
Gefühl dass viele Bauern haben dies der
Graben sozusagen zwischen den Bauern der
Gesellschaft und der Politik wird immer
größer und die haben das Gefühl
subjektiv genau das wir sind an allem
schuld Insekten sterben an der
Trinkwasserqualität am Klimawandel und
so weiter obwohl wir uns doch ständig
versuchen an eure Regeln die in den
Hauptstädten Europas und der Welt
gemacht werden zu halten und diese
Regeln machen nicht wir die Macht die
Pol nicht der ist schuld sondern die
euplwirtschaft ist Schuld genau und die
haben das Gefühl dass sie in den Augen
der Gesellschaft zunehmend nichts mehr
richtig machen können und da kommt jetzt
der zweite Faktor ins Spiel das ist auch
einer der Gründe weil es da dieses
Schmuddel Image gibt dass junge Leute
zum Teil oder oder Kinder von Bauern
sagen ich ich will das nicht ich mache
dieses Geschäft nicht weil ich habe eh
nur immer Ärger und dann bin ich so ein
so ein so so so so ein Schmutzfink der
da irgendwie die Umwelt verpestet und so
weiter und dann noch kommt noch
irgendwiner und schreit Glyphosat und
dann stehe ich endgültig mit dem Rücken
zur Wand ich mach es keinem recht
gleichzeitig sitzen die Leute in ihren
gut beheizten Altbauwohnungen und wollen
ökolebensmittel wollen sich möglichst
moralisch gut und und und und intakt
fühlen sozusagen und und wollen aber mit
alle dem nichts zu tun haben und das
Schnitzel wächst bei Rewe in der
tiefgültruhean wächst das Schnitzel ja
vielleicht tatsächlich im Labor aus
zellfleisch produziert oder es gibt
andere andere Dinge aus Pilzen gemacht
z.B die absolut wie Fleisch schmecken
und wo man keinen Unterschied sieht und
so also das alles wird sowieso kommen ja
und das wird auch noch die deutsche
deutschen Fleischwirtschaft den gar raus
machen also ich glaube dass das sowieso
noch am Horizont dämmert auch wenn das
jetzt ein Thema ist was passiert ja
nicht nächstes Jahr aber das wird
irgendwann passieren also was naiv ist
an dem was Frau Duwe da geschrieben hat
stellen wir uns wirklich mal allen
Ernstes vor wir würden wirklich ernst
machen und würden alle Subventionen
streichen ne dann ist klar dann würden
sich die Lebensmittelpreise
wahrscheinlich in vielen Bereichen mehr
als verdoppeln alles wäre sehr sehr sehr
viel teurer das GBE natürlich sowieso
ein riesigen
Aufschrei und was käme dann europäische
Gesetzgebung Freihandelsabkommen und Co
ja wir würden aus anderen Ländern
hochsubventionierte Lebensmittel zu sehr
günstigen Preisen kriegen das passiert
ja jetzt schon ne wir kriegen ja auch
Fleisch aus allen Herrenländern
gegenwärtig und unheimlich viele Zutaten
die wir in der Küche normalerweise
verwenden die man alle in Deutschland
herstellen könnten kriegen wir aus dem
Ausland manche noch mit den
entsprechenden Flugkosten und
Frachtkosten versehen und so weiter sind
immer noch wahnsinnig günstig das heißt
also wenn wir aufhören unsere Bauern zu
subventionieren daen unsere Bauern weil
sie von der Billigproduktion im Ausland
erledigt werden deswegen ist es
überhaupt gar kein realistischer
Vorschlag der Vorschlag würde ja nur
funktionieren wenn Deutschland seinen
Agrarmarkt abschottet und wenn er
sozusagen
endeuropäisiert
würde D haben wir ja gute Gründe gehabt
warum wir den Agrarmarkt mal europäisch
ausgebaut haben übrigens ein wichtiger
Grund war politisch ne frankreich wollte
das ganz ganz unbedingt ne
die waren immer enorm dahinter und die
Deutschen haben die Franzosen für die
europäische Idee begeistert indem sie
auch sehr weitreichend auf die
französischen Vorstellung damals
eingegangen sind aber klar ist am Ende
wenn diese ganzen Subventionen alle weg
wären und wir ehrliche Preise für unsere
Produkte
zahlen müssten dann gäbe es Tumult ja
dann wäre von einem Tag auf dem anderen
würde die Butter das Doppelte kosten und
die Tüte Milch das Doppelte und so
weiter und da weiß jeder so kann man
natürlich natürlich nicht regieren und
schon gar nicht in angespannten Zeiten
da ist also Lebensmittel formal billig
halten ich sag ja formal ja weil der
fakor werden sie ja mit Steuergeld
finanziert ne aber den Anschein wararen
dass Lebensmittel sehr günstig sind ist
glaube ich existentiell wichtig für den
Fortbestand unserer Demokratie mm ist
wahr ja ist wahr ich habe ein sehr
interessantes Gespräch gelesen mit
Reinhard Kaiser
mühlecker toller Schriftsteller der ganz
ganz viel Österreicher der ganz ganz
viel war der selber Landwirt selber
powerauer und der ganz ganz viel zu dem
Thema auch schreibt und bei dem ich
immer das Gefühl habe der der spricht
mir so aus der Seele weil er so diese
Situation beschreibt die ich auch von
von zu Hause aus Südtirol kenne die die
Bauern die ich dort erlebe das sind in
allererster Linie erstmal
nebenerwerbsbauern das heißt das sind
Leute die haben einen Job und nebenbei
sind sie noch Bauer und das machen die
nicht weil das irgendwie äh so so
unendlich viel Geld bringt und so
unendlich viele Subventionen bringt
sondern das machen die weil sie es
machen wollen und wir verstehen habe ich
häufig das Gefühl an Landwirten nicht
das hat mülecker auch mal gesagt dass
die sich eher umbringen würden als den
eigenen Hof zu verkaufen den Sie von
Ihren Eltern und deren Eltern geerbt
haben selbst wenn sie damit auf einen
Schlag viel Geld einlösen könnten warum
tun die das nicht ja weil diese Leute
eine Tradition haben weil die die stolz
sind auf das was sie tun ein ein
normaler Südtiroler Bergbauer
beispielsweise die sind auf dem Papier
faktisch alle Millionäre wenn die morgen
alle ihre Höfe an irgendwelche
wohlhabenden Zahnärzte aus Mailand oder
München verkaufen sind die alle
Millionäre und trotzdem haben sie alle
kein Geld weil das natürlich ein Wert
ist der quasi nur auf dem Papier da
steht die die können sich in dem Moment
frisch machen finanziell wenn sie es
verkaufen sie tun es nicht sie sie
arbeiten rund um die Uhr ich kenne so
viele Bauern dort weiß
du machen die harte harte Arbeit gehen
morgens um 6 Uhr in Stall oder noch
früher und es ist völlig egal ob Neujahr
ist oder Geburtstag oder oder oder
irgendein anderer wichtiger Feiertag
völlig egal die Kuh muss gemolken werden
dann arbeiten die den ganzen Tag durch
teilweise dann noch hart auf dem Feld
und nachts geht's dann in die Fabrik um
dort irgendwelche Kabel für die deutsche
Autoindustrie zusammenzuschweißen das
ist die Realität z.B von vielen Bauern
da bei mir zu Hause äh und das sind
Leute die die die die die wollen das
machen und ich glaube wenn wir diese Art
zu leben auch das Wissen das damit
zusammenhängt wenn wir das Verlieren das
ist in ein enormer Verlust für unsere
Gesellschaft und das bedeutet dann auch
so eine das bedeutet leerstehende Höfe
bedeutet eine entleung über was wir
reden du hast am Anfang völlig zurecht
ich rede jetzt über kleinbau genau du
hast nämlichf gesagt den
durchschnittsbauern nicht gibt also wenn
wir hierau irgendwann keine
landwirtschaftliche Intensivhaltung mehr
haben wo 3000 Schweine sich in einen
einzigen Stall zwäen dann würde ich das
in jeder Hinsicht als ein Gewinn
betrachten und kann darin beim besten
Willen keinen Verlust sehen ja also
außer Verlust für denjenigen der diese
Stelle da hat was anderes ist es
Landwirtschaft als Bewahrenswertes
Kulturgut und könnte man sagen ja liegt
die Zukunft vielleicht in ökohöfen und
so weiter aber die haben natürlich die
gleichen Schwierigkeiten ne der Markt
für diese Produkte die teurer sind der
wächst nicht in der Geschwindigkeit in
der erwachsen
müsste und auch hier Abhängigkeit von
Fördermitteln die mal kommen oder dann
mal wieder nicht kommen und dann hat man
zu viele Tiere und dann wieder zu wenig
und so weiter also auch das ist ja ein
ausgesprochen schwieriges und mühseliges
Geschäft mhm ist richtig und deswegen
ist das natürlich und da hast du ja
gleich am Anfang völlig zurecht drauf
hingewiesen natürlich unheimlich
schwierig über den Beruf des Bauern zu
sprechen ja weil zwischen dem
agrarunternehmer auf der einen Seite und
dem familienführten Kleinbetrieb wo auch
noch Familienmitglieder wo anders
arbeiten klaffen natürlich Welten und
ich hatte am Anfang gesagt wir haben die
Bauern die wir haben so wie wir sie
haben weil das politisch gewünscht ist
also wir müssen uns überlegen was wir
politisch wollen also rein theoretisch
kann es ja auf eine Monokultur
hinauslaufen dass am Ende nur noch die
großen übrig bleiben die ohnehin von
Brüssel begünstigt werden und dann
stirbt der kleine Familienbetrieb der
stirbt dann irgendwann aus und wenn der
Hof nicht verkauft wird dann wird er
vielleicht noch als Feriendomizil oder
sowas äh genutzt oder vermietet mhm und
das wäre ja eigentlich die
schrecklichste Zukunft die wir uns
vorstellen können und die andere Form
von Zukunft wäre man müsste viel viel
mehr für den kleinen Bauern tun und viel
weniger für die großen Agrarfabriken und
da sind selbst die Bauernverbände werden
ja dominiert von den großen ne die die
Bauernverbände sind nicht die
interessenslobby des Kleinbauern so und
diese Interessen Lobby der großen der
agrarfabrik der großerzeuger und so
weiter genau genau Kleinbauer hat
eigentlich im Zweifelsfall keine Lobby
manchmal nicht mal in seinem eigenen
Verein das das das ist genau der Punkt
und und die sehen sich genau diesen
riesigen übermächtigen Konzernen
gegenüber ich meine die die die Preise
für Grund und Boden sind in den letzten
Jahrzehnten global immer weiter nach
oben gegangen und und ich ich ich habe
das damals irgendwie auch in in England
gesehen als wir zwe Z 19 dort gedreht
haben das war sehr interessant das ganze
Land ist in der Hand von wenigen
Großgrundbesitzern die dann auch die
Gesetzgebung für sich so drehen wie sie
sie brauchen also gab's mal Subventionen
sozusagen für einzelne Tiere D hat man
gesagt nee warte mal dann hat ja nur
unser pechter was davon wenn der da
jetzt irgendwie Kühe und und Schweine
und Schafe und Ziegen und so weiter hält
lass uns doch lieber sagen es gibt die
Subvention einfach auf die Fläche
Klammer auf die gehört ja dann
glücklicherweise uns Klammer zu das
heißt da da fließt dann die Kohle wieder
genau zu denen die den das Geld ohnehin
schon zu den Ohren rauskom kommt und mit
dieser mit dieser Art von Spekulation
hast du es ja auch in in in in in
Mecklenburg und in Brandenburg und so
weiter mittlerweile zu tun riesige
Konzerne ir welche Investmentfonds und
so weiter kaufen einfach landpachtenland
um damit zu spekulieren es gibt g in in
Südtirol die Debatte da wurden riesige
Almflächen gepachtet von irgendwelchen
Leuten die irgendwo in in in Mailand
sitzen oder in Sizilien oder sonst was
weil sie dort angeblich allenwitschaft
betreiben und in Wahrheit haben die
nichts damit zu tun es ging darum
Subventionen abzukassieren völlig
krankes System aber könnte man
zumindestens nicht das verbieten ja das
ist ja der Punkt änder doch die Regeln
und änder sie so dass sie
nachvollziehbar sind und dass das System
in irgendeiner Weise irgendwie gerechter
wird aber das ist und dann wird man
sagen das muss europaweit geregelt
werden und europaweit wird gar nichts
zum gerechten
geregelt das sowieso nicht also man muss
einfach gucken dass man da auf
nationaler Ebene einfach wieder mehr
Entscheidungsgewalt bekommt mhm damit
man tatsächlich Landwirtschaft jetzt
steuern und lenken nicht nach Brüsseler
Vorgabe also wiea Bürokratie und
Vorschriften und drohen ja sondern im
Sinne von fördern bestimmte
Entwicklungen gezielter fördern
nachhaltiger fördern und auch mit einer
gewissen Durchschlagskraft fördern kann
mhm genau gab ein interessantes
Interview mit mit Ewald Frie der ist
Professor für Neuere Geschichte in in
Tübingen selber auf einem Bauernhof in
Münsterland aufgewachsen ein Hof und elf
Geschwister ist ein tolles Buch hat er
geschrieben der Stille Abschied vom
bäuerlichen Leben preisgegründtes Buch
übrigens der sagt das hat lange
Tradition also dieses sozusagen
konfliktreiche Verhältnis zwischen
Bauern und Staat und ich musste ein paar
mal dran denken weil und habe mich auch
hat mich teilweise auch belustigt wie
wie rebellisch diese Bauern dann doch
sind
so so kenne ich die so erlebe ich die
immer und der Satz ist immer wir
brauchen die alle nicht im Zweifel habe
ich meine eigenen Kartoffeln und mein
eigenen Weizen und wir machen unser
eigenes Brot die können mich aller
marschlecken das ist so ein Satz den ich
so so häufig h alt wieange solange wie
es Bauer gibt das wird schon im alten R
nicht anders gewesen sein und die Anzahl
der Bauernaufstände in der geschichteau
sind enorm mhm genau und Bauern sind und
das ist das zweite auch immer
strukturkonservativ ne es gibt ja
Bereiche in der Stadt ändert sich so
viel Kultur ändert sich so schnell
Technik ändert sich so schnell Industrie
ändert sich wahnsinnig schnell muss sich
schnell ändern immer wieder anpassen und
so weiter und Landwirtschaft war über
sehr lange Zeit her etwas konstantes
etwas in längeren Zeiträumen denkendes
und so weiter und das färbt natürlich ab
es gibt wenig linke Bauern mm
undb wenig
fortschrittsbeggeisterte ja ja also es
ist eher konservativ und
strukturkonservativ von der Mentalität
ne also das das Sein bestimmt das
Bewusstsein mhm ich glaub übrigens freie
hat darauf hingewiesen sagt das geht
schon so in den 1870er 1880er 90er
Jahren los da haben sozusagen die die
die die globalisierten Getreidemärkte ne
wir reden von 1870 1880 haben damals die
Bauern erstmals Deutschland weit
zusammengebracht und da ging es eben
sozusagen nicht nur um Ökonomie sondern
die haben gespürt da kommt jetzt diese
Industriegesellschaft und das bedroht
uns alles ja und da entstehen dann so
ein A 90er Jahren sagt er so die ersten
überregionalen
Lobbyorganisationen mit denen dann
Bauern sehr einflussreich und auch sehr
erfolgreich wurden ne genau wir haben
früh gelernt sozusagen ihre Interessen
ja notfalls auch mit Gebrüll und mit der
missgabel in der Hand gegen den Staat
durchzusetzen ja oft in der Allianz auch
mit rechtsradikalen Kräften ja 20er
Jahren z.B war gab's heftige Allianzen
zwischen zwischen den den
Rechtsradikalen der damaligen Zeit und
den Bauern und das ist übrigens auch so
ein Triggerpunkt in der aktuellen
Situation wo die unglaublich empfindlich
sind wenn man ihnen medial quasi
unterstellt ja ihr seid ja alle so von
so irendwelchen rechtsradikalen
unterwandert macht die wahnsinnig sauer
ma die zu Deppen erklärt es erklärt sie
ja zu Deppen die von anderen geführt
werden ja man traut dem Bauer
offensichtlich nicht zu ja dass er sein
Widerstand selbst organisiert man man
glaubt da sindeimliche Strippenzieher
dahinter die das Ganze für die Bauern be
kstelligen und deren nützliche Idioten
sie sind ich meine das ist ja auch ein
Anschlag auf das Selbstbewusstsein eines
jeden Bauern also Fakt ist natürlich
dass Rechtsradikale Gruppierungen
versuchen sich Ihre Scheibe davon
abzuschneiden das bezweifelt keiner aber
dass die Bauern quasi die nützlichen
Idioten von Rechtsradikalen sind ist ja
wohl eine
fehinpretation so genau das aber sag mal
das psychologische rich noch
abschließend und kurz auch mit dir
gesprochen weil du vorhin so sagtest
verrohen wir quasi als Gesellschaft ich
finde ja sehr interessant am Ende dieser
Woche eigentlich zu sagen
oder für mich erwächst so die Erkenntnis
ich habe diese Bilder mit Robert habbeck
gesehen und so weiter dann dann dann
sprichst du mit dem einen oder anderen
der sagt na ich kenne Leute die da dabei
waren da gab's schon ein Versuch davon
von irgendwelchen Leuten aus dem Umfeld
der AFD da was zu starten und zu zündeln
und so weiter genau aber die sagen auch
pass auf der Mann der dort mit der Fähre
ankam war jahrelang deren Land
Wirtschaftsminister und die mochten den
also robert habbeck war ein durchaus
beliebter Landwirtschaftsminister in
schlesig-holstein und eigentlich wollten
die mit dem meine Runde quatschen so
stellen die das da ich ich ich ich sag
mal so wenn es so war und wenn du dir
den ganz ganz überwiegenden Teil dieser
Proteste ansiehst der ja sehr friedlich
abgelaufen ist dann muss man doch sagen
am Ende dieser Woche ist das doch in
Wahrheit nicht der Nachweis dafür dass
dieses Land zu tiefst gespalten ist und
auseinander fliegt sondern ganz im
Gegenteil dass diese Demokratie
eigentlich sehr lebendig ist dass wir
uns streiten können und ohne dass es
dabei komplett ausartet und gleich der
nächste Umsturz in der Luft liegt ja das
würde ich genauso sehen
und mich berufend auf meine eigene
anekdotische Evidenz mein Fahrrad war
noch
da und deswegen habe ich ja beschlossen
im Podcast die die These zu vertreten
wir verohen nicht aber wenn aber wenn
wir wenn wir es realistisch betrachten
also es gibt sicherlich
verrohungsverbale verrohungen durch
soziale Netzwerke und in sozialen
Netzwerken ja das ist jetzt sozusagen
die digitale Gosse ja und die die
Stammtische sind sichtbarer geworden und
das färbt ab und das beeinflusst den den
Umgangston aber ich glaube dass das was
da auf der Fähre und mit Robert habbeck
passiert ist dass das kein Beweis für
eine verrohungsthese ist also ich kann
mich noch sehr gut daran erinnern wie
Angela Merkel im Osten auf das
allerübelste sexistisch von einem Mob
angegangen und beschimpft wurde ich kann
mich daran erinnern wie Helmut Kohl im
Osten mit Eiern beworfen wurde und zwar
nicht V einem sondern von mehreren
Kartons ja wie eine aufgebrachte Menge
versuchte den Kanzler zu fassen und der
dann sozusagen dieser Menge entgegenging
also es ist ja nicht so als ob es so
solche Dinge in Deutschland früher nicht
gegeben hätte du hast jetzt gesehen wie
nur ganz kurz fürs fürs Protokoll wie
Olaf Scholz der Kanzler im Westen übelst
beschimpft worden ist ne bei seinem
Besuch in Niedersachsen also da merkst
da gibt's gar kein gr arit e
Parteifreunden können gefährlich sein
SAR Wagenknecht hat man eine Torte ins
Gesicht gekriegt Joschka Fischer ein
Farbbeutel der dazu geführt hat dass ih
irgendwie der teilbe Trommelfell
geplatzt ist also all diese Sachen sind
natürlich ist das nicht schön das ist ja
völlig klar ja aber es ist auch nicht so
als ob jetzt dadurch jetzt hier auf der
Fähre eine völlig neue Qualität
entstanden wäre mhm also da muss man
auch vorsichtig sein also wir neigen ja
dazu weil wir unsere Demokratie aus
guten Gründen und völlig zurecht als
gefährdet einstufen gefährdeter als sie
früher war äh in in allem was jetzt
irgendwie die öffentliche Ordnung stört
einen fundamentalen Angriff auf diese
Demokratie zu sehen und da sollten wir
etwas vorsichtiger sein also man kann
die Sachen auch groß machen dadurch dass
man übertreibt mhm und noch mal darauf
hingewiesen also glaube es ist
mittlerweile relativ klar dass das was
sich da rund um diese Fähre kommend von
der Hallig Hoge abgespielt hat das ist
da natürlich den Vers gehab das von
rechts zu anterwandern aber ich glaube
man muss trotzdem vorsichtig sein wor
man die alle dann sozusagen in diese
rechte Ecke reinschiebt undal sehr sehr
schnell passiert genau genau muss man
aufpassen würde ich auch sagen aufpassen
also richard hat Spaß gemacht mit dir
über Landwirtschaft mal zu reden
und be beim Wolf werden wir irgendwann
ein vernehmen herstellen irgendwann in
einem späteren Leben ich sag mal das ist
mein Großer Vorsatz für dieses Jahr am
Ende des Jahres habe ich soweit also das
kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
weil sozusagen meine prägende
wolfserfahrung habe ich im Landesmuseum
in Hannover
gemacht Landesmuseum von von Hannover
gab es einen ausgestopften
Wolfskopf und da drunter stand der
Würger vom lichtenmoor das werde ich nie
vergessen und und das war sozusagen der
letzte niedersächsische Wolf der da ich
habe mich seitdem nie wieder mit der
Geschichte beschäftigt im vermute mal 18
19 Jahrhundert irgendwann da erschossen
worden ist und mir hat der Wolf so leid
getan ich bin dann immer um diesen Kopf
von diesem Wolf rumgeschlichen und ich
habe gedacht wie spannend und wie schön
wäre es doch wenn es in Niedersachsen
wieder Wölfe geben würde ich habe meinen
Opa gefragt damals ob das denn möglich
wäre und so und der der Bestand dann
auch daraus wä gut dass das nicht so
wäre sonst könnte man irgendwie nicht
mehr in Ruhe in Hannover durch die
einriiede gehen wo es vermutlich nie
Wölfe gegeben hat angepflanzter
Stadtwald aber das nur am Rand
aber ich f das so schön wenn es wieder
Wölfe gibt und das ist so eine prägende
Erfahrung da wirst du nie gegen ankommen
weißt du das schöne ist Richard da sind
wir total einig und sogar Christian
Lohmeier ja der seine Schafe verkaufen
musste wegen der vielen Attacken von
Wölfen würde das genaus so sagen ein
Held in der Realität genauso in diesem
Sinne in diesem Sinne dank dir sehr rich
hat Spaß
gemacht eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF